بحر متفرع عن البحر الاسود ومتصل به عبر
مضيق كيرش خلال الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا استطاعت موسكو السيطره على كامل
شواطئ هذا البحر
وباعلانها ضم المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
الاربعه قالت روسيا ان البحر اصبح تابعا
لها بالكامل
في اول ايام الحرب اتجهت القوات الروسيه
من القرم الى الشرق عبر مقاطعه زابوريا
وحاصرت مدينه ميلوتوبول قبل ان تسيطر
عليها في الاول من اذار مارس
شكلتوبول وهي ثاني اكبر مدن زابوريا نقطه
العبور والحصار لجميع المناطق على بحر
ازوف
وبحلول منتصف مارس استطاعت القوات الروسيه
ان تصل خطوط الامداد بين قواتها في القرم
والقوات الانفصاليه المدعومه منها في
وكان حصار ماريوبل واحدا من المصطلحات
الاكثر تكرارا في الاشهر الاولى للحرب
لاسيما مع انها اكبر المدن على بحر ازوف
حسست كتيبه اعزوف وهي من مجموعات
المتطوعين الاوكرانيين على شهره واسعه بعد
حصارها لاسابيع في مصنع ازوف ستال للصلب
اخر معاقل القوات الاوكرانيه هناك في
العشرين من ابريل انتهت المعارك في
ماريوبل باستسلام كتيبه ازوف عوده المعركه
والحصار وفقا لكياف بارواح ما يزيد عن 25
الف مدني شهد بحر ازوف بعدها تفجير جسر
القرم الذي يصل شبه الجزيره بالبر الرئيسي
في روسيا باستخدام شاحنات ملغمه كانت
تفجير مرحله فاصله في الحرب اذ بدات موسكو
بعدها بالرد بقصف العديد من مرافق البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه